Things about the hate to see that I wish I knew earlier
as a Year 12 student who just finished an accelerated
hate to see course.
The hate to see marks that Nessa email you
or text you are actually aligned and not wrong.
What does this mean?
It basically means that when you hear someone say, oh,
I got a 95 in biology or chemistry,
it doesn't mean that they only lost five marks in total,
but it meant that their marks were
adjusted as to how others in New South Wales performed
sitting the same test.
And so if you're thinking, oh,
so how do I know what Mark I'll need to get
for example,
a H to C Mark of 90?
Well, you can use the H to C rule Mark starter base.
And so for each of the different subjects,
they tabulate students
raw marks and their corresponding HSC Mark.
If you take Maths Advance,
for example,
the 2023 cut off for a,
B and 6 was 79.
But then for 2021 it was 74,
which indicates that the 2021
HSC was obviously a bit harder.
So they had to lower the Mark cut off for a band 6.
I hope this change your perspective
so you get a rough guide on what marks
you should be aiming for,
for your goal
hate to see Mark or ATO.